[Music]
[Applause]
we always love talking to albert breer
he makes a smarter senior nfl reporter
for the monday morning quarterback
i'm going to present the team you
present the biggest issue and how will
it be solved
let's start with the arizona cardinals
with kyler murray
the biggest issue i think right now
would be the relationship between the
quarterback and the
team and i know that that's you know
kind of uh
like i i guess it's an obvious thing now
uh but i do think it's a unique
situation man um you know i i think it's
in a certain way it's what we're going
to see with every quarterback right and
in one way it's after three years in the
current system the way it's set up you
draft a quarterback in the first round
that decision comes after the third year
and you look at most of the guys who got
big second deals from their teams after
being drafted in the first round carson
wentz jared goff to sean watson patrick
mahomes josh allen those guys all got
deals after three years so that in that
way
this is like a lot of these situations
but because kyle are so tied to cliff
and because things ended in such an
uncomfortable way and because even
though they just signed extensions to
the gm and the coach cliff kingsbury and
and steve kind there still is like
unease within that organization
you can understand where if kyler puts
two and two together he might say
i'm very specifically here because of
cliff
they're kicking the can down the road on
my extension
and if we don't get something done this
year and for one reason or another
cliff's not here in 2023
well then
is 200 250 million dollars going out the
door so
you know it's a it's an interesting spot
to be in and i it feels to me like you
know kyle is very much holding the
cardinals feet to the fire here
and
it's coming at a time when there are
questions on his leadership in the
building and so if this means he's
missing april and may and june
in that place the problem kind of
compounds on itself if you can find it
kind of follow that
yeah i think that's interesting so he
wants to get jump started in case
something happens to cliff kingsbury
then he's still getting that that
contract that he wants is that what
you're saying
well and think about it this way too his
college teammate was baker mayfield
baker mayfield was way down but was
asked to wait a year ago is that
extension coming for baker now
like you know what i mean like so
i think in a lot of cases a lot of times
like players and they shouldn't be they
shouldn't trust teams but why doesn't
connor murray bet on himself like dak
prescott did
well because i mean baker mayfield bet
on himself and how'd that turn out you
know what i mean like and i think
because the price points gone up to a
certain level
again like
you know these become more difficult
decisions for teams and the cardinals by
the way haven't said they're not going
to do a deal for them now the cardinals
just said why don't we wait until the
summer let's see if we get something
done in the summer the problem i think
kyler sees here um this is just kind of
me putting one piece together with
another
um the problem i think kyler sees here
is okay so if i report to the training
camp in july
and contract talks go nowhere
where does that leave me then i gotta
get ready for the season at that point
my leverage is gone so if i don't push
the envelope now i wait till the summer
and i'm in the middle of training camp
it's very hard for me to kind of
push the issue while i'm getting ready
to play the season it's much easier to
push the issue in february march
the green bay situation is always
interesting but brian brian guticunce
the gm was asked have you heard from any
teams about
trade offers
and he answered it by saying no haven't
heard from anybody
that means you're open for business
albert
instead of saying
we're not trading aaron we we want him
to be here we expect him to be here now
you're saying no i haven't heard from
anybody but if you know anybody who's
interested in getting a quarterback
coming off an mvp season let us know
i think brian goode is being very
careful with his words right now
because if he says we're not trading
aaron raj what does that say to aaron
that says
we control the situation you don't and
aaron doesn't want to see that
and i don't think the packers want to
have to navigate another awkward
offseason the way they did last year
so i think their priority is getting
aaron back on the team and if you're
telling aaron we are in control and we
will listen to offers and then we will
make a decision well then that takes the
control out of aaron's hands and so i
think they feel like they're in a really
good place now damn it the best place
they've been in a while with aaron and
effectively and i think i've said this
to you before
like personally on a personal standpoint
i think the issue is largely fixed like
the there was never an issue between
aaron rodgers and matt lafleur and the
issue between aaron rodgers and brian
gudekunst and the issue between aaron
raj and mark murphy
for the most part isn't there anymore
but you think that's why there's there
hasn't truly been any are you trying to
tell me denver has not at least inquired
about it i don't know if i believe that
i don't know if i believe that i think
the easy thing to say is no we haven't
gotten any calls because you don't want
to talk about it right like i like i'd
imagine
someone is inquired because when you
talk to teams here in indianapolis right
and you know how this goes like all
these teams are meeting in the hallways
and they're meeting with agents and all
that different stuff's happening here
like when you ask anybody about the
quarterback market what potentially
could happen with russell wilson what's
going to happen to sean watson what's
going to happen when you meet garoppolo
everybody's
response is well you gotta wait for the
aaron rodgers domino to fall and i knew
the likelihood is that he stays a packer
but how do you figure out when that
domino is gonna fall how it's gonna fall
if you're denver a team like denver
carolina washington what you do is you
call the package you know and you ask
and i think right now
and and look
good could be playing with with
semantics here a little bit you know
like because if
like somebody calls him and says
well are you guys ready to talk about
aaron rodgers no we aren't is that
really a trait call you know i just
think he wants to avoid the drama in
general like i think if you like the
answer both your questions i think the
priority right now for
for for green bay
is to avoid stepping over themselves
it's a delicate situation they want
rogers back i think deep down they
believe he's going to be back they'll
probably have to negotiate a new
contract for him and right now it's like
it feels to me at least like they're in
don't screw it up mode
do you want to get in on the uh tom
brady mike florio bet that we have going
on here
what is it okay
paulie bett mike floria florio says that
uh tom brady will be the starter in san
francisco week one
week one okay yes and it's a pie to the
face so uh if it doesn't happen florio
gets a pie to the face uh if it does
happen then paulie takes a pie to the
face which side you own
i don't think brady i just gonna sound
like such a cop out um i don't think
brady knows the answer to that question
like i think that's why he left the door
open and that's why he handled his
retirement the way he did and this is a
guy dan who has been i'd say like
actively afraid of the idea of
retirement he had no
what he's gonna do with himself he
doesn't know he's gonna channel his
competitiveness like this is a guy who i
think for the last
i don't know like the last 10 years like
whenever this first one on his radar
you're not answering the question albert
i know
i i i don't i personally think there's a
better chance than not we see him play
at some point again do i know do i think
it's week one maybe not but i think we i
think
like i don't think he left i think he
left football i think the reason he left
football was because
maybe he wasn't wild about his
particular situation
the family stuff plays into it too
um
you know i think you know if
the niners come along and because here's
the here's the key thing
is if you're asking him right now to
buckle down and play you're asking for a
12-month commitment if the niners come
to him in august or september and maybe
trey lance hasn't developed the way that
they they had hoped right
then what are they asking for they're
asking for like four or five months
how different is that it's a totally
different thing right
so
i think it's something that's on kyle
shanahan's radar i think it's something
that's on tom brady's radar like i i'm
with florio that i think it's a
possibility do i think it's a certainty
when i take a pie to the face for
uh for it not happening i don't know if
i go that far okay
yeah that's our litmus test of you know
how much you firmly believe in a story
uh
you know i'm watching chris ballard the
colts gm saying that they don't really
know what they're doing at the
quarterbacking position
uh it's been seven weeks since they lost
to jacksonville like what the hell have
you been doing
how long does it take to figure this out
where you go do we want him or do we not
want him and then what happened so what
what do you think the colts will do
the operative question here is then what
um i i don't think this is a yes or no
i think this is a what's available to us
question and i think aaron rodgers
coming up the works to some degree
and carrying his decision into march
i think has sort of made it more
difficult for teams like indianapolis
like carolina like washington like
denver
to really gain clarity on their
quarterback options and you know like in
denver and washington carolina we know
those teams are going after quarterbacks
i think with indianapolis there's way
more gray area
to get rid of carson once they'd have to
eat 15 million dollars um and
you're so you're talking about like the
investment in a new quarterback would be
whatever it costs to bring in that guy
plus the 15 million dollars that sunk
costs to get rid of carson wentz and
i think that for that reason
like whoever they're looking at has to
rise to a certain level for them to pull
a trigger on it so do i think they're
out on carson once they're probably out
on carson wentz
could i see him back as like almost like
a de facto stop gap year because they
don't have a better option this year
yeah i could see that i think this is
going to come down to
not just carson once but their options
outside of carson once and i think
that's why they're sort of leaving a
light on forum
dak has
surgery minor surgery they always say it
when it's not on you it's when you have
surgery you know i never viewed all of
my surgeries and they went that's minor
knee surgery i go no it's still surgery
but it's on his non-throwing shoulder
um
is this
a bigger issue feels like it's being
made a bigger issue because the media
loves covering the cowboys
yeah i think i think it'll be all right
like i do think you worry a little bit
about the accumulation of injuries with
dak to some degree because he has been
nicked up a lot and you know i think for
quarterbacks that are deployed the way
he was deployed early in his career um
where they did run them and they ran
them by design a bunch
i think that's something you have to
kind of keep on your radar so am i
worried about this specific injury not
so much would i be a little concerned
about the accumulation of injuries and
if i was the cowboys was i would i be
sort of trying now um he's close to 30
years old would i be trying now like
look at him and say
we need to get you to do a better job
protecting yourself we need to do a
better job protecting you in the way we
call games we need you to we would like
you to evolve into a guy who's you know
going to play a game that's going to be
more sustainable from an injury
standpoint i think all those things are
on the table so i'm not worried as much
about this specific injury but the
accumulation of injuries i think is
something that the cowboys have to have
on their radar is albert breer senior
nfl reporter lead content strategist the
monday morning quarterback new interview
rules at the combine there in
indianapolis
uh have you heard about
what they're
asking teams to do or not do the
language the tone of the questions um
yeah
you know i guess it's the modernization
of it you know what i mean like i think
it's like there's things that were
accepted because at the root of these
interviews um
you know and these are the most the
second most important thing like
everybody makes a big deal out of the
workouts the two biggest things here to
teams they're number one the medical
number to the interviews and
these guys are coached to such a level
on how to answer questions and how to
act in these interviews
that you know it's almost like
fraternity hazing you know what i mean
like it's like
like forever the way that they handled
that was we got to break the guy down we
got to make him uncomfortable because
then he's going to reveal to us who he
really is
and
i mean
i grew up you know i think we all grew
up with that sort of like coaching
teaching like like a lot of us did
like people of this generation of this
generation the age of the the guys the
age that are coming into the nfl right
now
i don't think grew up with that so i
think there's like a modernization going
on know course lawyers are involved with
this stuff too and you know that um but
yeah i mean there's a modernization
going on in the way they handle these
situations and it does feel like i mean
and i i think maybe this is like a
little bit like postcode stuff but
um you know i think as they take the
combine potentially move it and you see
teams sending less people here you know
you see guys certain guys at the top of
the draft now maybe reverting back to
saying you know what i'll just wait till
my pro day
it feels to me like this week in
indianapolis there's been sort of a
reshaping
of the way the combines run and the way
certain elements of the combine are run
so it definitely feels like a lot of
things are in flux the interview process
is part of that
great to talk to you have fun there at
the combine thank you bud thanks for
putting up with my hostage cam too i
appreciate it oh here's another one
over under first quarterback taken
13 and a half picks
over
ooh okay
paulie's got a bet pie to the face on he
says he's gonna a quarterback will be
taken
on the first 13 picks let's do a
positive face on that okay so you got a
pilot face bet with florida i'll do pie
to the face all right yeah i had
albert carolina panthers
i have not had one i'm probably i have
not had a single team tell me that any
of these quarterbacks would be in the
top five quarterbacks last year i had
another team tell me that the number one
guy that they have like the the top
rated quarterback in this year's class
for them has a would have the seventh
best grade among quarterbacks last year
behind the five that won the first round
in davis mills this is a really really
shaky here at quarterback okay pie to
the face so breer's got the over
paulie's got the under yeah this is not
really fair albert's a guy with lots of
information and thought and and he
really yeah you know talk to him nobody
talks about yeah we usually don't do
research on this show right
yes absolutely
uh that's albert breer the uh lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback